- Today I'm getting my dream pet.
For as long as I can remember,
my dream pet has been a potbellied pig.
And today, I get to take care of one.
I'm taking care of a
pig named Hamlet today.
I'm gonna meet her at her house,
learn her routine with her family,
and then we're gonna
bring her back to my house
and see how we do alone together.
(happy music)
- I'm Melanie.
- And I'm Michael.
- And we're Hamlet's humans.
I got her when she was six weeks old.
When I bought her from a breeder,
she was a micro, mini pig.
Soon after, I found out
there's no such thing.
She's a potbellied pig.
- What's the difference
between taking care
of a dog and taking care of a pig?
- Their behavior is not the same.
A lot of people think
that you just train a pig
how you would train a dog,
but pigs are very different.
They remember things.
Sometimes they'll seek
revenge, and pee in rooms.
- So they're really smart and they like to
seek revenge, which I relate to.
- You know, she gets into everything,
she's very curious, she
needs constant attention.
We can't leave anything
out that smells good.
They need to get to know you,
because they're naturally
prey, they're kind of weary
of new people and new things.
- This table is all the stuff that
she needs to live her best life.
- So I made a checklist for you.
Snacks is first on the checklist.
Pumpkin, carrot.
I have an outfit for her.
The dressing started
because of her fair skin.
It was easier.
- I relate to that.
I relate to Hamlet more than I expected.
(Melanie laughs)
- Then we have a harness and a leash.
A scratcher, very important.
Pigs love belly rubs.
You are gonna do Instagram.
Do you want the pink car?
- [Kelly] Yes.
- [Melanie] Okay.
- Let's pack her up and take her home.
So here's Hamlet.
(pig oinks)
You okay?
You wanna go on an adventure?
Now I have my dream pet for a day.
It's happening.
It's really happening.
We're on our own now, and hopefully,
I make a best friend today.
Okay, we are home.
Putting you down is hard.
You're so heavy.
Oh God, oh God, oh God.
Okay?
We're good.
I think she's finding crumbs.
She might like me more, knowing
that I have food around.
(happy music)
We're taking a tour.
We're in my bedroom now.
She's cleaning the floor,
and I appreciate that.
She's a good roommate.
I can't believe I have
a pig in my bedroom.
I'm gonna put her litter box in a corner,
'cause I know she likes corners.
She's very messy.
- [Woman] Uh oh, she's on your carpet.
(Kelly laughs)
- Let me wipe you.
Oh, she's mad.
(pig oinks)
Oh God. Oh no.
You graze and I will wipe.
Thank you.
Aw, she was good.
She's like a little kid, but you need to
wipe their face because who knows
what's on it, and she's
just like "No, no."
You want water?
I feel like she's having a good time.
I'm gonna take her out to lunch
because I'm a good friend and pet owner,
but I need to get her harness
on so that she's safe.
Her mom told me it's
really hard to put on her
because it's super tight,
she doesn't really enjoy it,
so I'm gonna just kinda do what
she told me to do, which
is chase her down and
sort of, like, get her head in there.
I'm a little nervous.
Hamlet.
You okay?
I think that means she's fine.
We did it though.
We did it.
Wanna go to lunch?
I'm trying to eat lunch and my pet pig
is making a great escape from her
stroller, and I'm proud of her.
That's crafty.
You wanna go home?
(bouncy electronic music)
That lunch was not super comfortable,
mostly because people just kept coming up,
which is fine, but it was
also a little bit intrusive
in a way that it was like,
they were touching her
and I just got a little nervous
that she might get nervous.
One of my friends is stopping
by just to drop something off.
She doesn't realize what's
in my apartment right now.
You weren't planning on hanging
out, but just come inside.
- [Lizz] Should I be scared?
- [Kelly] No.
- Oh my God, what?
What is that?
- [Kelly] That's my pig.
Her name is Hamlet.
You can go over to her.
Look.
- Oh my God.
- We're friends now.
If you sit.
Jump.
Ah, good girl.
Okay.
- Oh my God, how is she--
(Kelly laughs)
She just eats it?
- Okay, bye.
- [Lizz] She's bringing it
all over the place, too.
(happy music)
- I'm gonna try to put on her outfit,
because I promised her owners that I
would do an Instagram for her,
because that's part of her daily routine.
And this is going to be interesting.
(bouncy music)
Turns out you really need
to get in there with this,
so I figured out how to get it
and I think I pulled it through.
Now she's just really happy on my
lap, which makes me really happy.
I've had a full pig on my lap before.
This is something I've always wanted.
Okay, she has her pink car here.
We brought it with us for this Instagram
opportunity that I was tasked with.
But we're so happy right
now just like this.
Do we really have to go?
Yes? Okay.
I'm gonna put on one more little
piece of clothing for her.
Now she looks beautiful, but she
always looks beautiful, let's be real.
This is kind of hard.
So I feel like this is
a good stopping point
because I'm scared to go any further.
(jazzy trumpet music)
Today was amazing.
I got my dream pet for a full day.
We did a bunch of stuff.
And now ending the day
kind of just in my bed,
where I would sleep with my pet pig.
Just to have her here burrowing
in my blanket in my room,
it feels really special,
and it's something
that I didn't know if I
would ever get to do, so.
I will say that taking care of pigs
is definitely not for everyone.
You really do need space, you
need time, you need grass,
and they just deserve all
the attention they get,
but they do need a lot of attention.
I might just stay here
the rest of the day,
the rest of my life,
so you guys can go now.
Bye.
(twangy music)